in recent times feminists have started
to Grapple with a very difficult
question as we all know feminism is a
layered and nuanced ideology that always
finds itself at the Forefront of the
most important and challenging
discussions of the day so here's the
quandry they're dealing with now how can
a feminist woman be
empowered while still being a
materialistic cheap ass is it possible
to be a strong independent woman without
also having to pay for dinner you know
th this is the Dilemma it's the great
philosophical debate feminists are in a
difficult position because they've
insisted for many years that they don't
need no man that they're a bunch of girl
bosses large and in charge they declare
that the old codes of chivalry and
patriarchal and paternalistic uh you
know are patriarchal and paternalistic
and they have to be abolished they
shouted from The Mountaintop that they
are exactly equal to men the same as men
in every respect and they certainly
don't need a man to take care of them or
provide for them they have growled and
they have shrieked and they have made
their voices heard and then to their
horror many men started to take them
seriously men listen to these
protestations and and they said okay
well if you say
so as you wish you can have what you
want which means among other things that
when the bill is put down on the table
many men will not instinctively reach
for it anymore they will let the
independent girl boss pay the tab or at
least pay half of it but feminists have
recoiled at this development no they cry
we we we want to be independent but but
not like this not if it me I have to pay
for my own Santa Fe salad at
Chili's but how do they make this case
can they really become a damsel in
distress as soon as the bill is placed
on the table and then get right back to
being empowered and Progressive a few
minutes later how does that work well
different feminists have come up with
different ways of grappling with this uh
important question here's one influencer
on Tik Tok giving her answer watch the
thing that I have realized about this
topic is that there are so many women
that really do advocate for not going
50/50 right and for me I definitely went
through like my well I'm a feminist I
shouldn't have an issue going 50/50 face
right when I was younger but recently I
started to realize just how difficult it
was accepting going 50/50 with men and I
have come to the realization that it is
because even as a feminist it is the
only benefit women real out of the
patriarchy a benefit we did not create
the rules for y'all did but it is still
a benefit that women get from the
patriarchy so whenever Men start
advocating for like well what about
equality pick up this check or whatever
it in when I hear that it's like you're
literally trying to rid me of the only
benefit I get out of the patriarchy the
only like think about it for a
second is there any other benefit we get
out of the
patriarchy uh let me step in there for a
moment I I'll answer your question man
but but first I I have to point out how
by your own logic anyway this is the
most pathetic stance I've ever seen
anyone take because by your telling we
are a patriarchal society and the
patriarchy is an abject evil you say and
yet you wish to extract whatever
benefits you can from it this thing is
evil and terrible and should be
dismantled but I also want to reap its
rewards this makes you significantly
worse than the patriarchal men who
according to you uphold an oppressive
system but at least you know we don't
see it as
oppressive you do see it that way and
yet you also uphold it just so that you
can get a free meal at the Cheesecake
Factory so pathetic doesn't even begin
to describe it but to your question is
there any other benefit that you get out
of what you call the
patriarchy the answer is yes
um a few you know there are a few
benefits like I don't know uh the house
that you're currently sitting in um
every bridge you've ever driven across
every car you've ever driven in
electricity indoor plumbing democracy
Freedom civilization itself just to get
the list started so all of these things
were all largely invented established
built maintained by societies that you
would call patriarchal so the patriarchy
as you define it has given you basically
everything of value in your entire life
so what else has it given you like
everything every single thing you like
has been given to you by what you would
describe as the
patriarchy other than that sure I guess
it hasn't done much for you but Tik Tok
isn't the only place where this debate
is Raging over at the LA Times They Are
grappling with the same issue uh a new
column poses the question this way
should men pay on dates as reparations
for the gend wage Gap the writer Gene
Guerrero explains quote for years I
split the bill on dates as a Latina from
a lineage of women whose lives have been
micromanaged by Family Patriarchs I
thought I was Breaking Bad generational
patterns by interacting with men as
equals rather than as providers but
recently I started getting push back
from some of my friends they argued that
because of the persisting gender pay Gap
it's actually how it's actually now
properly feminist to expect men to pay
on first AIDS and contribute more
financially in relationships one friend
instructed me quote don't even think
about reaching for your purse the
thought of possibly coercing a man into
paying for my dinner however just seemed
wrong still this discussion did make me
wonder should I expect men to pay on
dates as a form of reparations for
generational
harm yes the harm again of building
every home and every bridge and every
airplane you know that's what men are
doing fighting and dying in every war
keeping all the lights on
Etc such great harm that men have
perpetrated against women every societ
on Earth would collapse in like 5
Seconds without men doing all the things
that men do all the things that men do
and and that men almost exclusively do
in fact but all of this somehow amounts
to generational harm that's the argument
but it's not an argument that every
feminist buys well they buy the
generational harm thing but they don't
buy uh that this relates to uh to uh the
issue of who pays at dinner the article
continues quote the problem with framing
being taken out to dinner by a man as a
form of reparations is that it's
privately consumed Juliet Williams a
UCLA UCLA gender studies Professor told
me it's not an accounting for Injustice
in any way that's visible or
acknowledged we have to be careful not
to just label anything that's personally
advantageous as somehow politically
Justified but many women believe that in
our unequal times it's only fair for men
to pay and not just because men still
out earn women women also tend to spend
more on date preps such as makeup and
manicures to meet female beauty
standards Some Women Believe men should
cover cover the cost of not only the
dates but transportation to and from in
a viral Tik Tok video la resident Gabby
FaZe 27 says I expect a man to pay for
the date yes the whole entire date that
includes my Uber to the date and my Uber
back to my house she told me she sees
this as a compensation for women's
sacrifices in relationships it's also
proof of serious interest I want to feel
wanted she said now the writer goes on
to examine both sides of this crucial
issue by the end she's arrived at no
particular conclusion you know some
women say that men should pay in order
to make up for our many sins others say
that it isn't enough you know that that
that the only reason we shouldn't do
that is only because it it couldn't
possibly be enough to assuage uh our
guilt for the patriarchy and then there
are others who point out that women in
many cases are doing better financially
than men and so the financial burden
should shift over to them in those cases
and nobody's sure what to do everyone is
very confused so um let me see if I can
lend some clarity to the situation so
there are a few things going on here
first we see the propensity on the left
to in so many cases dismantle something
and then try to recreate kind of a
simulacrum of that thing that they just
destroyed so they they have no ideas of
their own they have no real vision of
any kind so they often end up
plagiarizing the very ideas that they
oppose that's why many feminists have
ended up right back where it started
expecting men to pay for dinner the
difference is that now the reasons
behind this expect a the underlying
framework is flimsy and superficial and
ridiculous so in the past men paid for
dinner because it was considered a man's
duty to provide it was his place it was
his role there was dignity in it there
was a long tradition behind it there was
the noble and heroic concept of chivalry
you know all of that went into the fact
that a man would would clearly pay for
dinner well feminism hates everything
Noble and heroic and masculine and
traditional so all of that had to go but
it still wants free meals at Bonefish
Grill so the expectations of shivalry
were reinstated without the philosophy
of chivalry underlying them so now men
are expected to pay but not for Noble
and strong and clear and traditional
reasons but for whiny and weak and Petty
reasons we went from it's a man's duty
to provide which is a strong and clear
and positive and truly empowering
vision of what the Sexes are supposed to
be doing to now it's well you have to
pay to heal my generational trauma which
is unclear and weak and resentful and
Petty and negative profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things not to like about tech Giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of their
products well the good news is it
doesn't take much for you to take a
stand for less than $7 per month you can
join me and fight back against big Tech
by using
expressvpn big tech companies make their
money by tracking your searches video
history and everything you click on and
then selling your personal data
expressvpn helps you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your IP
address a unique identifier that every
device has that allows big Tech to match
your activity back to you that's why I
use expressvpn on all of my devices to
make it much more difficult for them to
exploit my data for their own profits
and the best part is how easy it is to
use the expressvpn app I just tap one
button on my phone or computer to turn
on it's as simple as that your data is
your business visit expressvpn.com
walow use my Link at expressvpn.com
slatwall show to get three extra months
free that's
expressvpn.com
slatwall show feminism uprooted all of
the of the trees from the forest and
then tried to put the trees back without
the roots but they're not trees anymore
they're just big logs sitting
precariously on top of the
soil of course not every feminist agrees
that the expectations of chivalry should
be reinstated without the chivalry
itself some say that men should not pay
some say it should be 50/50 some say
payment should be a portioned based on
income level but they all seem to agree
that there is something missing you know
they're not
satisfied and and and this is the case
not just with paying for dinner I mean
the paying for dinner thing is a is a is
a
microcosm of the confusion that has come
to Define pretty much every aspect of
the male female interaction every aspect
is now a source of uncertainty and
debate men and women don't know how to
interact with each other anymore they
don't know how to date each other they
don't know how uh they don't know what
their expectations should be and what
their responsibilities are and what
expectations they're supposed to be
fulfilling from the other person and
which expectations are reasonable or not
they don't know any of
that and these are all things that again
up until uh feminism these are things
that people didn't worry about because
it was all known
so all of these things in in the dating
World particularly particular these
these sources of anxiety and the
questions and I don't know what to do
and I don't know what they're thinking
what you have to realize is that that if
you go back not that far into the past
these anxieties almost didn't exist at
all because everybody knew what they
were supposed to do they knew what their
roles
were but feminism tore all that to
shreds and as always with the left they
replaced it with basically
nothing this uh this newfound
Freedom isn't making anybody happy it's
only created anxiety and
paralysis you know we didn't have this
problem under the old system with the
old concept of gender roles men knew
what was expected of them women knew
what their own part was uh there was no
awkwardness when the bill
came and with their with this basic
understanding of their own respective
roles and responsibilities they could
move on and live their lives and get to
know each other without the anxiety and
the and and the stilted weird
uncertainty that defines the male female
interaction in the Modern
Age so thank you again feminism you made
everything worse and nothing
better you didn't solve any problems but
you did manage to create a bunch of new
problems that didn't exist
before and for that reason feminism is
once again certainly not for the first
time and certainly not for the last
canceled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts